Look, if they want to go through your
bags, all you got to do is grab the bag
without the drugs. If they don't, then
grab the bag with the drugs.
That's how we get the drugs through.
We alternate it like that.
Everybody on the plane was like, "Bet
." "Dope." "Yeah, let's do it." I said,
that don't work for me. I don't like
that plan. I don't f****** like it.
My name on my bag. Don't touch my bag.
You touch my bag. I'll tell.
I'll f****** tell. I'll never forget
it. It's a true story. We're landing in
Mexico. Plane goes down.
I look out the window, look like an
episode of Narcos. I've never seen more
Mexican officers in my godd*** life.
They stay in the air. They got the
dogs. I've never seen dogs look through
the window of a plane.
The dogs. When I saw that, when I saw
the dogs, I said, Oh, boy, y'all going
to jail? Y'all going to f****** jail?
They smell it. The dogs smell it
already. Little Mexican man comes on a
plane after the door goes down.
He starts speaking Spanish.
Keep in mind, I don't know Spanish.
I know a couple of words, and I know
the rhythm. I know the rhythm of
Spanish. For the purpose of this joke,
I'm gonna hit you with the rhythm.
The reason why is because I want you to
feel like you were there.
I'm telling you ahead of time.
These are not real words, okay?
They're not real words.
It's going to sound like it, but it's
just the rhythm. But don't make me
laugh because I got to stay in the
character. Don't make me f****** laugh.
So he started off he started off calm
and then escalated. This is exactly
what he did. Okay.
Donde? Donde.
Donde. Donde esta?
Hmm? Donde esta nuera?. Nuera.
Que tiaro. Salty Sotto siete.
[Fake Spanish]
Looking right at me. He looked at me
dead in the f****** eye. He go, que,
que. I don't know what the f*** que
mean. But he wanted an answer.
He looked right at me. I panicked.
I didn't know what to f****** do.
I panicked. I said, queso.
So I just said it.
I said, queso.
I thought about the cheese.
Queso cheese. I don't know what the
f***. Queso.
He thought I was being a smart ass.
He said Oh.
Queso.
No diano.
You ever hear Spanish people talk real
fast and it just sounds like a bunch of
clicks? This is this is what he said.
[Fast speaking Spanish]
[Fast
speaking Spanish] Exito!
This is my nightmare. We going to jail.
I get up. I got my hands up.
I'm cooperating. We get off the plane.
They got a security booth right there.
You got to get in the booth one by one.
When you get in the booth, you got to
press the button. When you press the
button, it go red light or green light.
Let me tell you something right now, if
you press that button and you get a red
light, you can cancel Christmas.
It's over for you. You hear me?
It's over for you.
It get dark as f*** when you press that
button. It's red.
[Fake Spanish]
You press the button, it's green,
they're a different person get.
Que pasa! Put a f****** hat on you and
start dancing. Dum, dum, dum.
You don't want to dance, but you're
scared. So you do it anyway.
Please don't kill me.
I'm first. I got to press the f******
button. He's looking right at me.
I almost said.
I almost said they got drugs.
I swear to God, I was f****** nervous.
My stomach was bubbling, my ass was
wet. I was farting.
It was too much. I was nervous.